this has been a chaotic and emotionally
wrenching week in America and so we've
been dedicating our television time to
conversations with people who really
understand what it's like to be black in
America in 2020 earlier today I had a
great talk with my very talented friend
Sam Richardson so let's go to that now
my guest tonight flew across the world
last year to introduce me to the country
of Ghana and it's incredible people he's
a very talented comedian who starred on
the acclaimed HBO series veep as well as
the Comedy Central series Detroiters and
I'm so glad he's with me
tonight please welcome our really good
friend Sam Richardson hey Sam hey Connor
thanks very much for being here I know
that you would express like a little bit
of concern or maybe trepidation about
coming on tonight is that true or well
yeah personally you know I I feel
there's like people who are more
eloquent and expressing kind of what's
happening or better you know figurehead
for kind of is that the responsibility
of kind of expressing what's going on
right now right
but ultimately it came to the decision
like well you know I am a black man in
America so I have empirical knowledge of
the situation yeah and all I can do is
speak for myself and you are my friend
and I appreciate your idea of like
raising black voices to speak so I
figure this is a good opportunity to do
that yeah I think there there doesn't
need to be I know what you mean because
there are many times when all of us in
different situations feel like
inadequate I'm constantly thinking why
am i talking not just in this situation
but in a lot of situations and then I
think this isn't just about people who
are specialists in
black history or black history in
America it's not just about them it's
about everybody who has something to say
who's experienced firsthand what this is
like so how are you how are you as a
human being
well that's a that's that's that's the
question right every every phone call
every meeting everything start with that
and it's like a really you know double
dutch kind of answer fact matter I'm I'm
incredibly sad incredibly angry you know
but but what's happening but but at the
same time I'd say I'm not surprised
and I think no black person in America
is surprised or shocked by what's
happening or what's happened we've known
this whole time I think what is I don't
even know I want to use the word
encouraging but what is encouraging is
watching the actual reaction to it you
know the thing that it's been happening
for amper you know but now it's a time
where there's a solid fight back so
that's that is an encouraging thing but
you know I'm I'm saddle time I'm a metal
time I'm filled with anxiety and I watch
you know I can't keep off my phone I'm
seeing what's going on right but you
know at the same time I try and and just
take care of myself that's what you know
what we need doing McCants yeah that's
it I can't let myself get into full
despair I don't let myself get into
action that makes it does make sense
the I'm curious because you and I went a
year ago to Ghana you showed me your
country that you're that that your
family is from you have this really
fascinating worldview because you come
from two worlds you know you
spent time growing up in Ghana but also
Detroit so and so you have this
perspective that is to me absolutely
unique and and maybe we could learn from
uh well yeah it's true yeah I grew up
between two places grow between Ghana
and Detroit and like in Ghana the faces
are all black so I have no fear of being
a prejudice for the color of my skin
there you know black people represent
the wealthy elite the middle class and
the lower class you know they're so you
know that experience I have and then to
just oppose that to my life in the
United States there is no bolder
contrast to know that here I mean
legitimately its second-class citizen
you know have you talked to your mom
does she have a take on what's happening
right now
my mom is in Ghana right now as matter
of fact and you know she and she's been
kind of like quarantined up this
question because of covent never saying
and like you know the borders are closed
there still but she's just worried about
my safety being here you know she's
nervous is she is she's frightened my
dad is in Detroit right now you know
same sentiments the fear that kind of
exists I'm not a parent but a fear that
exists for parents to to have your
children navigating the world we know
there is a threat to their lives and
their livelihoods
you know that's it that's justice the
reality what can you tell me what your
experience was just uh I mean I both one
of them I remember I remember I was at
my girlfriend's house if this is in
Detroit suburbs in in Berkeley and late
night a drunk driver outside hit a pole
no hit it crashed it
right next to my car the police came
investigating and I said I went out side
I was like oh officers and the guy
screamed at me so quick and him the gun
and I mean maybe in that instant I had
kind of forgotten what the protocol is
for black people dealing with police you
know because I was like trying to help
out stopping curious to see what was
going on with my car that was right next
to this thing and that's if there was a
there was like a bank robbery happening
you came here for a drunk driver yeah
yeah and a bystander what do you think
my plan was know what else to do
you know I was just like epi I called my
dad he's like yeah remember and he said
he said remember hmm I mean other time
another time that was much younger and I
went into a swearing this store Sports
Authority and I was walking through the
aisles and kind of just like looking
around perusing I went to walk out of
the Sports Authority and this woman
grabs me and yanked me into this rooms I
know what you did I know what you did
the cops are coming the cops are coming
I know what you did and then you know
the police showed up and they're like we
know that you stole something and I just
couldn't III was just fully confused you
know I'm like 12 years old you know and
I I miss threat this woman like who's
like oh I can miss this this boy must
have stole something and I have the
proof of it and I'm going to directly
get it out of him please come and
they're as aggressive they check the
footage of me and the aisleway and I had
taken off my watch to put on a baseball
glove
and put my watch in my pocket and the
response as though I had committed an
armed robbery yeah yeah and she knew
that calling the police was going to
elicit that sort of respond like I had
no Porter and just well you're 12 you're
12 years old yeah yeah now this is in
Dearborn Michigan how do you contain
that anger do you know I'm saying how do
you because I because I you don't this
is from my perspective but you know in
all the time we spent together it's hard
for me to imagine you containing those
infuriating humiliating experiences do
you not I mean and so now in the time it
should come out but where do you what do
you do with that how do you live in the
world with that kind of anger I mean we
all we all have to yeah I mean if we
were all to shoulder the amount of
frustration and fear that we feel we you
know we wouldn't be able to exist in
society its I mean to make it to make it
nerd in the movie Avengers you know
captain be like they're surrounded by
the the villains the the the aliens are
attacking Captain America's like hope
now be a good time to get angry and hope
looks to him says that's my secret
captain I'm always angry yeah I'm always
angry yeah you know but I'm also I I
can't let that anger make me I can't let
that anger dictate my life
and stop me from experiencing life you
know we that's that's true for all of us
there's no way that we can see what
happens in the world and what these
cases of violence against us and not be
angry you know and these things boil
over
you know we're watching right now these
things boiling over you know I've been
talking this week trying to look for
just trying to listen and also trying to
figure out how can this not be just
another incident that we all process
there's unrest and then we move on so I
was back in the same situation six
months from now two years from now
what's the way forward and one of the
things that wkl bells told me yesterday
was he said it's action let's see your
work letís work and I thought that
really spoke to me which is yes there's
a lot of talk right now and talk is good
and there are a lot of people trying to
symbolically and I'm talking about white
people trying to show that they care but
then so much more about it is it feels
like right now is about what are you
going to do what are people going to do
moving forward what is your work and you
got to keep at it
meaning we there's a lot of clearly a
lot of work here to be done so I don't
know if that's well I I think right now
there's a sweet spot right because
everybody is at home with kovat
everybody's closed in and are faced with
it they have to see what's happening and
there's not like immediately after a
distraction you know you like like and
go to work and then like kind of like
forget about what's up happening if
you're you're you're bombarded with it
every day you see what's happening you
see it's happening it's impossible to
ignore
right now so it's and in that shows that
these things aren't new but you can
watch like now everybody's watching you
see how close together they are and
that's
constant these things didn't just start
when everybody was at home watching
their phones and that but their their
constant so now everybody is is forced
to act you know so like moving forward
it has to be nice to remember how they
feel right now yeah everybody has to act
for right now and do as much they can
people we want to be distracted as much
as we can because we want to keep our
world the same way it is we're
comfortable in it but right now people
are uncomfortable and if they're a
member that discomfort you know it was a
bit of this it's called the pain for
change you know how much stress or how
much pain can you put on a situation
before you have to change it you know in
order to you can't okay like if
somebody's pinching you you know person
who gets pinched the second this pin it
doesn't mean anything so you don't move
and somebody pinches harder you don't do
this maybe just hard it's a stop you
know you have then you change your
circumstances so right now we have to
remember this pain before all the other
distractions the world come in you know
and we're watching we're watching things
are happening you know all four officers
have been charged in the you know the
Brianna Taylor Taylor case has been
reopened watch watching these these
things that happen and then we keep on
it we can affect real change and that
there's nothing to like it's up to white
people and all people to educate
themselves educate themselves the
knee-jerk reaction of when somebody says
black lives matter to then say all lives
matter whether you are well intentioned
or actively trying to discredit the idea
of black lives matter pay attention to
what that is you know what what is it
that makes you say that do you really
believe that when a person says black
lives matter we're saying black lives
matter more or is it that the idea of
changing the system frightens you you
know I do these the questions you got a
say there's nothing more frustrating
truly than going through your comments
or going through my comments and I say
if something black lives
well all that matter no I said all lives
don't matter that once did I say a white
life doesn't matter not once I say Asian
life doesn't matter all I said it's a
black life matters matters well suppose
in Michael che in the standards like all
these first one that matters that's the
lowest talking point and opposition to
that is uh it's frustrating yeah there's
also I think a there's a fear of people
want it and again I'm gonna be specific
white Americans want to do things that
will help or make a difference or sound
like or be supportive and they might get
it wrong yes they might get checked for
it they may put up the like with the
internet you know people putting up the
the black tiles thinking that and and
it's well-intentioned
mmm-hmm but then it turns out to
actually not be helping and angering
some people and then there's a feeling
of well wait I just touched the stove I
thought I was hoping and I got burned
one of the things that I've been
learning this week is ya be wrong try
just keep trying and being embarrassed
or saying okay my bad I thought this was
the right thing to do it's not now I'm
going to try again my embarrassment is a
tiny tiny tiny price to pay
it's less than a mosquito bite you know
this idea that some that people are
going to try something get checked for
it online and then get angry and say
well I try shut off I put up a black
tile and now it turns out I'm not
supposed to do that so I'm out run it
watch Real Housewives cuz I try to help
and that's that well they
want my help so that's that I'm done
yeah you know what education do you go
in knowing everything about it what
person goes into college knowing
everything about the college courses
this is the time where people are trying
to learn and people need to learn so
part of learning is getting things wrong
and then checking yourself and then
applying that to the next time you know
I think people I would say like new
people can't let their fear of getting
things wrong or fear of not being able
to do the perfect thing or getting
things perfectly right stop them from
trying to do something you know those
are the steps you have to take you have
to get there and and just make the first
step at least and then let that
encourage you to see oh okay
I can do something and then do the next
step and then between to the next step
you know but you people need to visit to
get the idea that they need to just go
straight into being Martin Luther King
you're Malcolm X and like just from zero
to a hundred that's that's not rational
but you need to do something and then
learn from it and grow from it the
growth we have to grow in this mm-hmm
you know to back up view you took me to
Ghana for us to do a special about year
of the return the 400 years since the
first slave ships were leaving you know
Africa and we went to Ghana to
experience that moment and we ran into
this group of people from the Chicago I
think it's Trinity United Church and
they were all from Chicago and they were
visiting to experience this moment and I
think it was Kumasi yeah and I started
talking to them and it was beautiful
they were so fantastic and so moving to
speak to that I want to make sure we
show that clip because this is from a
year ago but I think it resonates now
probably more than it did then why is it
important for you to be here no it's a
time to remember those who came before
us yes Esther Islam this is really deep
to see those who resisted that's a major
thing they bring up those who were
resistors who fought back and a lot of
people did not make it so many people
have died on his journey to be stripped
and taken from their home right it's
kind of an awakening
we've only been free for roughly 160
years whereas we've been in bondage for
over 400 years
so physically yes we're free mentally
not so much for me personally I'm
realizing how much racial stress I'm
under every day in America I don't even
realize it
I don't even realize that when I walk
into spaces where I am a minority
I am constantly checking myself here I
don't feel that what I am here I feel
that I am at home one thing that is
striking is 400 years of slavery think
about it
400 years how many generations of people
good people that sit on the sidelines
and watch slavery occur this is a lesson
that we all need to learn is that if we
see injustice whether it's happening to
us personally or happening to our
neighbors we gotta find a way to speak
out and stand up the one thing that's on
my mind was with agar one of the guys
that when we went back to one of the
slave auction castles he said that you
can either be bitter which means you can
leave here weak or you can either be
better which means you leave here
stronger and so I thought about what
that been and what that meant is that
we've seen much agony and we've seen
much pain but he's also see much hope
and must promise and must glory so we
must tell the whole story but let us put
as much infant infant emphasis on the
hope and own glory and on the optimism
as we tell the story so that people can
say well there is a brighter day you
know how eloquent and how who's smart
and on target everybody was in that
circle everybody had a third it was
absurd
random group of I don't know if it was
20 or 25 people I I be hard-pressed to
go anywhere in the world and and grab 25
people and ask them all their opinion
and not one of them one of them was
anything less than then just beautifully
eloquent and powerful and teleprompter
such a beautiful moment and see you you
there's there's a every hard to say
every but black people we experience the
world that we must be knowledgeable of
it you know and so the you caught twenty
five people who are in a journey for
knowledge so every one of them has been
thinking and expressing their ideas so
specifically and and cultivating what
their feelings are and so you caught
them as a perfect time because as a
black person you have to be a scholar in
order to understand your feelings of
what's what what they had was what's
happened to you and what's happened to
people in this country for 400 years you
know it's hard to ignore you know so
it's so like those 25 people you you
caught a sweet spot well yeah you know
this is like I say it's it's almost like
it it must be endlessly frustrating to
have because I've been on this week I've
been talking to whether it's fan Jones
or W kamau Bell or you that that if
incident happens and then suddenly
everyone's asking you how do you feel
and educate me which is exhausting and
not your job it's not your job to
educate us it's our job to educate
ourselves and you know I'm just you know
if everyone I've spoken
to this week you're the one I know the
best and it's it's upsetting to hear
your stories and and because I know you
to be such an amazingly sweet and
sensitive person and I hate that 12 year
old or 20 year old you or 30 year old
you had to go through any of that I just
hate it's makes me it makes me nauseous
to be enough so that same so you know me
and this is just like a grin to listen
for anybody who's watching or anything
you know me and you know but I have this
experience
imagine that for every black person that
you know you know whether you know them
better than me you know them less than
me you know them to be a human being and
they've experienced this if that doesn't
call you to action then you got a call
you got to ask yourself what would you
know yeah
you know for someone who was worried
about you know earlier you were telling
me well I'm worried about I was had some
trepidation about coming on the show
because all these professional speakers
on racial strife and and and scholars
have been talking and I don't know what
my place is and your your fears were not
we're not valid because you've just
talked about your experience and it's as
powerful as anything I've heard this
week so you know I really do appreciate
it it's and I'm hoping it I would like I
would like to be optimistic I don't know
if you are but I would like to have I
always describe myself as a 51% optimist
I am right I'm aware I'm pessimistic but
I'm I'm I want to slightly lean towards
optimism and I want to hope that it gets
us to a better place if we doing the
work I think so I think
to keep doing the work I feel like going
back like you know there's no quick fix
to anything you know at 2008 we like to
Barack Obama and everybody patted
themselves on the back we're like yes we
did we fix racism we've gotten
that's done on the next case and we were
done with it you know
and then nobody went to vote two years
later nobody went to do it yes then like
like we need to educate ourselves on how
the government works so you don't put
this all on one person you have to work
the system and if the more we educate
ourselves the more we can see like and
there's hope out there we have to vote
you know we have to become a part of
this like and and and we can see we can
change things
who was that like the first black woman
mayor was just elected in Ferguson
mm-hmm just happen we can make change
happen
we have you just have to do it right and
we can't be discouraged by voting but
like like yes voter suppression is real
you know gerrymandering of districts is
real these things are real but with
overwhelming numbers you can't deny them
you know they say like you talk about
getting discouraged you know but like
can't gives courage
black people have been going through
this for 400 years here we having this
courage yet so you know I say why
friends yeah
y'all can either cheer Conan up tonight
you're a really good friend and a great
human being and thank you very much for
for sharing with me and for making I'll
tell you this I feel I feel better
not that that's the goal but I do just
having you in my life and I real
appreciate you talking to me well I
appreciate your friendship and I
appreciate you using this time to
elevate Elif late
I appreciate I'm gonna think that me say
that one more time I appreciate your
friendship this is what I was worried
about finish line and you I think
subconsciously you know what Conan's an
ass I can't I can't I almost put on
professors well but I do appreciate you
elevating Black Voices well let's let's
keep it going
let's keep it going and let's you know
again thank you so much and I just keep
thinking about my favorite moment I know
this is so silly to bring up at the end
but in Ghana visiting your mom at her
house seeing all this really cool stuff
you know the moment I'm talking about
tribal emblems pictures of chieftains
that you're related to proud warrior
stuff just amazing and then going down
and suddenly a bobblehead a Funko doll
Funko pop doll of your character from
veep is between remember that moment
just thinking like this is so great this
is our son had gone off and he's
conquered America this is what he's done
alright you take care and I'll see you
very soon all right all right take care